[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
بريطانيا اول دوله غربيه تزود كيف بدبابات
تشالنجر وتستعد لارسال مروحيات اباتشي
نا
عمليات البحث عن اربعه ركاب ماتز المستمره
ايران تفاجئ دمشق لا مزيد من النفط
المجاني او باسعار رخيصه وتطالب هالدفع
بالسعر العالمي
اللجنه العسكريه الليبيه المشتركه خمسه
زائد خمسه تجتمعوا مجددا في سرت وتبحث
انسحاب المرتزقه وتثبيتها وقفه اطلاق
النار
طبعا هذا ياتي بعد يوم من اعلانها السيطره
والكامله على مدينه سوليدار وهو نفته كيف
التي اكدت ان معارك طاحنه لا تزال تدور
هناك هذا وقالت الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
شنته عددا من الضربات الصاروخيه على مواقع
الجيش الاوكراني فيما افادت السلطات
الاخرانيه بمقتل 23 شخصا على الاقل بسبب
القذف الروسي وذلك على مجمع سكني في دنبرو
[موسيقى]
هذا هو من جانبها قالت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه قالت ان روسيا تدرس رفع سن
التجنيد طبعا لتعزيز الاحتياطيات في
تحديثها لاستخباراتي اضافت وزاره الدفاع
البريطاني اضافت ان رئيس لجنه الدفاع
بمجلس الدومه الروسي اندريه
اقترح مؤخرا ان تمدد روسيا السن الاقصى
للتجنيد العسكري من 27 الى 30 عاما وذلك
في المسوده المقترحه خلال الاشهر المقبله
من جانبيه اشاده يبقيني بريكوجين رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه بفعاليه قوتي في
اوكرانيا مشدده على استقلالهم عن الجيش
الروسي وفيديو له نسبه بريكوجين المكاسب
في شرق اوكرانيا الى قوته بعيدا عن
الوحدات الروسيه حيث اوضح ان الانضباط
الشرس لدى المجموعه هو الذي سمح على حد
قوله لمقاتله بالسيطره على المدينه تبدو
طبعا هذه التصريحات له بمثابه انتقاد مبطن
جديد للقياده العسكريه العليا الروسيه في
وقت تواجه فيه اتهامات بما في ذلك من بعض
انصار الرئيس بلادي ماركوتن بالافتقار الى
التنسيق والابتعاد عن واقع الميدان
المزيد معنى من ثياب مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بك حذيفه اخر التطورات
الميدانيه وما هو المؤكد حتى هذه اللحظه
انباء حول عدد الضحايا والمفقودين
والمصابين في المبنى السكني الذي تم
استضافه بضربه صاروخيه في مدينه روسيا
ارتفع عدد الضحايا او عدد القتلى الى 25
قتيلا وعدد من تم انقاذهم حتى الان الى 39
شخص بينهم سته اطفال
والقتلى 25 بينهم طفل واحد وايضا 73 جريحا
بينهم 13 طفله هنالك 43 شخصا مفقودا حتى
الان تحت الانقاذ الان تواصل همم يعني همم
الانقاذ والدفاع المدني ويصلون على العمل
تمصب اربعه ايام
الاستجابه والطوار واخيمتين للمتطوعين وما
زال همم وطبعا هنالك ايضا اختصاصينا نفسيا
يقدمون همم الدعم النفسي للضحايا
المصابين وايضا ل- اسر الضحايا ومن ما زال
لديهم مفقودين تحت الانقاض العمل جاري في
هذه في هذا الموقع همم بشكل عام طبعا اخر
تطورات طبعا هنالك مزيد من الهجمات التي
اطالت مدينه باخوت وضغط همم مستمر على هذه
المدينه كان هنالك قصف على مدينه باخبط
وكذلك افديفكو والكسا
تم قصف هذه المدن الثلاثه خاصه الاكسندر
كتعرضت اكثر من مره خلال النهار مرتين
خلال النهار ايضا هنالك محاولات التقدم
كانت من قبل القوات الروسيه في منطقه
سليمان في اتجاه منطقه الايمان قوات
الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقول انها استطع
الهجمات في تلك المنطقه كذلك في كوبلز كان
هنالك محاوله تقدم فاستطاعت قوات الدفاع
ايضا هذه الهجمات قالت ايضا وزاره الدفاع
عن القوات الروسيه تحاول تحسين وضع
الاستراتيجي في كوبر ولكن
القوات الاخرانيه تواصل همم يعني همم جعل
ذلك حسيرا كما وصفه همم هيئه الاركان
المشتركه العامه هذا بخصوص جبهات القتال
ولكن طبعا ايضا هنالك مشعات الطاقه التي
تضررت في يومين يعني من الامس وحتى اليوم
هذه المنشات هنالك بعض المنشات ما زال
جاري العمل على صيانتها وصيانه المولدات
في تلك المنشات ولكن اغلبيه المشاركه
مقاله شركه الكهرباء انها استطاعت ان
تستعيد عمل هذه المنشات الوضع الاصعب في
مساله الامداد الكهربائي هو في الكيبوردسه
ومدينه الفيف ميسون
بدات الحديث عن دو نيبرو والاعداد الهائل
في الضحايا المدنيين ومن بينهم اطفال كما
ذكرت همم هو همم هذا المجمع كان مستهدف او
همم ضربه طائشه ماذا ما الذي يمثلها هذه
هذا المجمع وهذه المنطقه
يعني طبعا ميسون استنادا على ما وضحه مكتب
الرئيس وكذلك
قائد الاداره العسكريه في دينيبره بطرس
وطبعا ااا بعد ذلك هو اكثر ممر علق على
هذا الامر وكذلك مستشار الرئيسكي ميخائيل
بدولاك قالوا ان هذا الاستهداف هو استهداف
لمجمع سكني مدني وهو كذلك ولكن هذا
الاستئذاف كان مقصودا باعتبار ان الضربه
كانت بصاروخ 22 وايضا هذه الصواريخ هي
دقيقه جدا لذلك الضربه وجهت بشكل دقيق كما
يقولون انه استهدفوا المدنيين همم بشكل
متعمد همم طبعا كسر عزيمه الاوكرانيين هذا
ما تقوله الجهات الرسميه طبعا
ايضا هناك سؤال في ما يتعلق بالامدادات
البريطانيه لكيف في ما يتعلق بالدبابات
وايضا طائرات الاباتشي هل هناك من معلومات
وشرح كيفيه وصول هذه الدبابات الى كيف
لوجستيا نتحدث وايضا فيما يتعلق بالتدريب
في علامه استفهام كبيره اين وكيف سيتم
التدريب
عندما نتحدث مثلا
يتطلب ان يسافر الجنود الاوكرانيين الذين
سوف يمثلون خبره لبعض بعد ذلك لنقل هذه
الخبرات الى جيش الاوكراني يسافرون الى
بريطانيا اسوه بما حدث الان يعني الان
بينما نتحدث في هذا الاسبوع اما ان وصلوا
او سيصلوا خلال هذا الاسبوع الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الجنود الذين يتدربون
على باترول كما نشر ذلك البيت الابيض
وتحدث عن ان هناك مجموعه من الجنود سوف
ياتون الى الولايات المتحده للتدريب على
بطاريات باتريوت الامريكيه كذلك نفس ذات
الموضوع طبعا همم المساعدات العسكريه في
الفتره الاخيره يعني ترتفع نسبتها بارتفاع
نسبه همم الهجمات والضربات التي يواجهها
الاتحاد الروسي على هذا الاساس يقوم
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتقوم الدول همم التي
تساعد اوكرانيا برفع مستوى الامدادات
عسكريه الان حتى برلين تدرس عمليه امداد
الجيش الاوكراني باليوبارد 2 وهي الدبابات
الالمانيه سوف يتم اتخاذ هذا القرار خلال
هذا الاسبوع قبل ان ينعقد اجتماع رمشتاين
وهو اجتماع وزراء الدفاع او يمكن ان نصفه
بمجلس استشاريين من وزراء الدفاع الدول
الشريكه ليه اوكرانيا وهو مجلس استشاري
املي فقبل يعني نعقد هذا الاهتمام سوف يتم
اتخاذ القرار من برلين
لك وانتقل مباشره الى الدوناتس
ومراسل العربيه رائد الاخضر رائد هل
تسمعني
مرحبا مرحبا ميسون اسمعوكي الميدانيه من
عندك
نقاء شماليه الغربيه ذهبنا لاستطلاع
الاوضاع العسكريه بالقرب من باقي شمال
المقاطعه بالفعل الاعمال العسكريه هنا لا
تتوقف والارسال العسكريه الروسيه
ممتده على طول الطرق الشماليه
بالفعل هناك همم رغبه اظن عند الجاه
لاكمال السيطره على كامل مقاطع
صوت القذيفه التي سقطت بجوارنا
انتبه على حالك رائد هل تستطيع ان تكمل او
تريد الاختباء هو الذهاب الى مكان امن
المعارك مستمره ميسون ونحن على خط
المواجهه القريب جدا من اشتباكات اجانب
الروسي والاوكراني وبالفعل هناك عمليات
عسكريه لا تتوقف
اعذريني اذا لم نتحدث عن التطورات في
سندار او في المناطق الاخرى لكن بالفعل
المنطقه هنا
ساخنه جدا
وهنا قصف متبادل نحن قريبين ايضا على
مناطق اطلاق النار من جانب الجيش الروسي
لذلك
هناك معارك ضاريه يرغب اجانب اذا تحدثنا
عن القوات المواليه لروسيا والجيش الروسي
بشكل عام في هذه المنطقه فهم يرغبون
باكمال السيطره على كامل مدينه ماريكا
المتاخمه
لمدينه دانيت في الناحيه الشماليه الغربيه
وهم يتقدمون بالفعل ويجرون عمليات تنظيف
او تطهير كما يصفونها لانهم سيطروا على
اكثر من نسبه 80% من
جغرافيا المنطقه كما انهم يرغبون
بتعزيزات وامدادات عسكريه من اواسط
المقاطعه نحو همم التي باستت مطلقه من عده
جوانب الشماليه والشرقيه
اذا شعرت بالخطر يمكنك انهاء هذا اللقاء
باي لحظه ولكن اذا استطعت ان تكمل كان
عندي سؤال في ما يتعلق بالبابنار وان كان
هناك تلمس لهذا الانفصال الذي نشهده من
خلال التصريحات الموجوده ما بينهما بين
الجيش الروسي
سؤال من فضلك ميسون
اولا بدايه اذا شعرت بالخطر يمكن لك رائد
ان تنهي اللقاء باي لحظه ولكن اذا تسمى لك
ان تكمل ان كنت تستطيع ان تكمل اللقاء
اتحدث عن باكنار في تصريحات تتحدث انها هي
المسيطره هي التي استطاعت ان تتقدم
بالنهايه وهذا في نوع من الانتقاد المبطن
كما قرا للجيش الروسي هل تتلمسون ذلك على
الارض من مشاهداتكم
همم نعم ميسون ااه بالفعل ااه التواجد
لمقاتلي فاجنر في المناطق الاكثر سخونه هو
مؤثر جدا وذلك ما صرح به القائد الاول
لقوات راجنر الخاصه التي
اختبر غير تابعه للجيش الروسي نسبيا او
تعمل يعني بقياده
بقياده خاصه مختلفه عن قياده الجيش الروسي
قال اليوم قائد القوات الخاصه
الوحيده التي حققت النصر في سوليدار بعد
عده اشهر من تطبيق
اول باول هو اكثر جدوله كما كانت تفعل
روسيا السابق وقرر ان همم ان يتقدموا من
ناحيه السندار ويقدم بلدات بلده والاخرى
وقال انه بالفعل نجحت هذه الخطه وتمت
السيطره وان قواته الوحيده التي لها الفضل
للسيطره على مدينه الدار من اجل التسويق
مدينه طاقم من النواحي الثلاثه
شكرا جزيلا لك ونتمنى لك السلامه
هذا هو مشاهدينا مع اشتداد المعارك كما
لاحظنا من خلال
العربيه صحيفه دمر نشرت مقالا يفيد بان
بريطانيا سترسل اربع مروحيات قتاليه من
نوع اباتشي الى اوكرانيا طبعا هذا ضمن
حزمه من المساعدات العسكريه الصحيفه قالت
ان مصدر عسكري رفيع المستوى صرح بان
المروحيات ستكون ضمن حزمه من عشر دبابات
تشالنجر اثنين سيتم تسليمها لاوكرانيا
قريبا بالاضافه الى 30 مدفع هاوتر بعيد
المدى ولم يصدر اي بيان او تاكيد لهذه
المعلومات سواء من وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه او من نظيرتها الاوكرانيه
هذا ورغم ان بعض الدول الاوروبيه بدات
تسرع في تزويد ثياب بالاسلحه يبدو ان
الامر نفسه بالنسبه لالمانيا سيحتاج بعض
الوقت اعلنت مجموعه رايه متل الالمانيه
لتصنيع الاسلحه ان تسليمها دبابات من طراز
لوبارد من مخزون الشركه لاوكرانيا لن يكون
قبل مطلع العام المقبل حتى اذا وافقت
الحكومه هذه المجموعه تمتلك اكثر من
اثنتين و20 دبابه من طراز اليوبارد اثنان
واكثر من 88 نموذج من الطراز الاقدم من
جانبه نشد السفير الاوكراني في المانيا
اليكسيما كيرف نشد الحكومه ضروره تزويد
بلاده بهذه الدبابات بشكل سريع وذلك قبل
المفاوضات المصنع بين الحلفاء الغربيين
بشان مواصله امدادات الاسلحه لاوكرانيا
بعد تردد دهما لاشهر بسبب مخاوف من
استفزاز موسكو المانيا تعلن تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات موردر القتاليه اما
بالنسبه للدبابات
فعل كليب ان تنتظر وفقا لصنع الاسلحه
الالمانيه
لاوكرانيا الا في عام 2024 لانه يجب
تفتيقها واعاده بنائها بالكامل وهي عمليه
ستكلف مئات الملايين من الجروحات
[موسيقى]
من جانبها فرنسا مستعده لارسال الدبابات
لوكليرك لحلفائها في النيتو بينما سترسل
بريطانيا 14 دبابه من طراز تشالنجر 2 ونحو
30 من المدافع ذاتيه الدفع طراز اي اس 19
بالاضافه الى اربع طائرات المروحيه هجوميه
من طراز اباتشي الى اوكرانيا في الاسابيع
المقبله
[موسيقى]
الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
الصومال تعلن على شان اكبر عمليه عسكريه
تستهدف حركه الشباب المرتبطه بالقاعده
اهلا بكم مجددا اعلن تصلطات مثاليه مصرعه
جميع من كانوا علمتني الطائره المنكوبه في
مدينه بخارى السياحيه وعددهم ما نتحدث عن
72 شخصا قالت هيئه الطيران المدني
النيباليه في بيان ان الطائره كانت ذات
محركين من طراز اي تي ار 72 والتي تديرها
شركه الجويه النيباليه بدوره اوضح رئيس
الوزراء النيبالي ان الطائره كانت في
طريقها من العاصمه كاتماندو الى مدينه
بخارى وسط النيبال فيما لم يتضح بعد سبب
تحطم الطائره يذكر ان مدينه بخارى تعد
مسار شهيرا للترحال لمسافات طويله في جبال
الهيمالايا كان مطار بخار الدولي بدا
عملياته منذ اسبوعين فقط وبحسب قاعده
بيانات سلامه الطيران التابعه لمؤسسه
سلامه الطيران فقد وقع 42 حادثا ممتا
ممثلا في نيبال منذ العام 1946
[موسيقى]
طائره اي تي ار 72 المنكوب
طائره تجاريه تصنعها شركه اي تي ار
الفرنسيه الايطاليه
[موسيقى]
دخلت الخدمه لاول مره سنه 1988
يصل عدد مقاعدها الى 78
تعملوا بطاقه التوربينيه
[موسيقى]
من طيارين اثنين
تعرضت هذه الطائره الاثني عشر حديثه تتحطم
نموذج بدايه استخدامها
تسببت هذه الحوادث في وفاه حوالي 466 شخصا
[موسيقى]
تستخدمها العديد من الخطوط حول العالم في
الرحلات القصيره
على كل المزيد معنا من اسطنبول الكابتن
الطيار احمد العجارمه خبير طيران اهلا بك
طياره احمد دعني ابدا بما انتهى به
التقرير عن الارقام نتحدث عن 12 حادثه
تحطم لمثل هذا النوع من الطائرات منذ ان
تم اطلاقا نتحدث عن عام 1988 هل هذا الرقم
كبير في قطاع الطيران او لا
مساء الخير بالنسبه ل 12 حرف طيران
عامه 1988 يعني بتحكي عن حوالي 35 سنه
15 سنه
نحاول نعرف الاسباب يعني المشكله بالطياره
تقول بانها امنه هل المشكله
من يدير هذه الشركات او هذه الطائرات لانه
همم بيقولوا حسب قاعده بيانات سلامه
الطيران التابعه لمؤسسه سلامه الطيران
وقعت 42 حادث مميت همم في النيبال منذ 46
فعلى عنا مشكله في هذا القطاع تحديدا في
هذا البلد تحديدا اولا الرقم ايضا هنا
مقبول
من
اقل الدول العالم
طبعا عندهم اول شيء في طبيعه المنطقه
عندهم كلها منطقه جبليه عنده بمعنى ثمن من
اعلى 14 قمه بالعالم
التضاريس اللي مكسور
فقدنا الاتصال مع الكابتن طيار احمد
العجارمه حول العوده اليه ربما في سياق
النشره ولكن نكمل في الخامسه الان وضعت
ايران قيود توريد على النفط الرخيص الى
سوريا الامر الذي تسبب في ازمه قامت طهران
بمضاعفه السعر الذي تدفعه دمشق مقابل
النفط الخام مما ادى الى نقص الوقود في
سوريا تزامنا مع انهيار اقتصادها وبحسب
وسائل الاعلام سوريا تسبب النقص في طوابير
انتظار امام محطات الوقود ايران رفعت
السعر من 30 الى اكثر من 70 دولار للبرميل
بحسب وول ستريت جورنال
في ايران ايضا تجتاح موجه واسعه من البرد
وايضا العواصف الثلجيه العديد من المناطق
وسط ازمه الطاقه في البلاد ففي محافظه
اراك وخراسان باته 90,000 ساكن دونغاز
بحسب مصادر محليه يقولوا المسؤولون ان
درجات الحراره وصلت الى مستويات غير
مسبوقه ما رفع الطلب على الوقود لمستويات
قياسيه ادت شده البرد الى توقف المدارس
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي اغلاق بعض محطات
الوقود وذلك في جميع انحاء البلاد في
الوقت الذي تتفاقم فيه الازمه يوما بعد
يوم اعلن وزير خارجيه ايران حسين امير عبد
الاهيان استعداد بلاده لارسال الوقود الى
لبنان
هذا واقد على واقع الازمه السياسيه في
البلاد تجمع المئات من البلوج صباح اليوم
امام منزل الرجل الدين السني المعروف
بمولىنا قرقيش في محافظه جلقستان لمنعه من
الذهاب الى محكمه رجال الدين الخاصه
استدعت السلطات هذا الرجل بعد تعبيره عن
مواقف داعمه للمتظاهرين وبعد انتقاده لقمه
السلطه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نعود الى طائره النيبال والتي تم
الاعلان مؤخرا عن ان كافه ركابها همم قد
تم الاعلان عن مصرعهم وهذه صور مشاهدينا
اوليه تصلنا الان لسقوط هذه الطائره طبعا
يتم تداولها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
قبل هبوطها ربما بثواني قليله على كل ان
اعود الى ضيفه من اسطنبول الكابتن الطياره
احمد العجرم خبير الطيران اهلا بك مجددا
كابتن طيار احمد كنا نتحدث قبل قليل عن
تضاريس هذه البلدان وربما اشرت انا في
سؤالي ان كان همم
لهذه التضاريس تاثير على الطائرات وربما
تكون جزء من الاسباب وراء الحوادث التي
تحدث
للاسف الانقطاع عن البث قد قليل بالنسبه
للسلامه الجويه في نهال هي ضعيفه جدا لذلك
فيني بالذات باخر 30 سنه صار عندهم 27
حادث يعني معدل حادث كل سنه هي اساسا
اجراءاتهم او السلامه الجوده عندهم متدنيه
طبعا هم بالفترات الاخيره بعد موقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي استقبال طائرات من نيبال
قبل ثلاث سنوات او اربع سنوات
معدل السلامه الجويه في البلد وفي تحسن
لكن ال همم التاثير التضاريس هو جزء من
همم
الحوادث يعني بس بحادث اليوم ما لها تاثير
اليوم انا حسب ما شفته حسب ما قرات وشفته
هذه الصوره هلا اذا شاهدتها وان كانت
قصيره جدا هل لنا ان نقرا ما الذي حدث في
هذه الثواني ربما
اللي حسب الصوره الطائره كانت السرعه
منخفضه اييه من بين من سوره الطائره انه
كانه عندهم محرك متعطل
كان طائره جايه اقل من الاتفاع المطلوب
عندما حاول يعطي يعني
يرفع الطائر لارتفاع اعلى عاده اذا كان
متعطل احد المحركات ممكن يؤدي الى انقلاب
الطائره لان هذه طائره فيها محركين محركين
تيربو لذلك اذا فقد احد المحركات اللي هذا
انا اتوقع طبعا
انه يرفع طائره همم
لما اعطاها باور اكثر الطائره وقلبت لانه
يكون الدفع من جهه وجهها لذلك اتوقع السبب
اللي انا شفته اليوم يعني همم
[موسيقى]
يعني كان بالامكان تداركوا هذا ما تقوله
كابتن طيار احمد
حاله الجو سيئه ارتفاع المطار يعني 2700
قدم
الحاله المسؤوليه تكمن على المطار تكمن
على همم الشركه نفسها المشغل او لا لانه
ما في صيانه معناها
الصيانه سجنهم صيانه مش قوي بس ما بعرف
القاهره لانه عارفين بشكل عام طائره عند
الاقلاع قبل الاقلاع يتفقدوها بكل شيء
يعني كل في هناك فحوصات معينه يتم تفقدها
كامله من قبل المهندسين لذلك توقعي ما
يكون فيها اي مشكله عند الاقلاع هلا تعطل
المحرك
يعني باي وقت ممكن يحدث بس الطيار عاده
بكون مدرب جاهز او مدرب بطريقه جيده انه
يتفادا يعني اي مشاكل
سقوط من اسطنبول نعم احمد العجارمه
الطياره
الطيار احمد العجارمه خبير الطيران شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
الصوماليه عشان ما سمته باكبر عمليه
عسكريه وذلك لاستهداف حركه الشباب طبعا هي
مرتبطه بتنظيم القاعده ودليل كم منذ اكثر
من 10 سنوات دعت الحكومه الصوماليه دعت
المواطنين للوقوف في وجه الارهابيين
المرتبطين بتنظيم القاعده وفي هذا الاطار
شدد السفير الامريكي لاري اندريه بالنجاح
الذي حققته قوته الامن الصوماليه في
معركتها التاريخيه لتحرير المجتمعات
الصوماليه التي تعاني في ظل تواجد حركه
الشباب
اكيد رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان دعم القوات المسلحه لكل
خطوه تقود الى الانتقال الديمقراطي
البرهان جدد ترحيبه بالاتفاق الايطاليه عن
اعتقاده بانه سيوحد شمل السوداني
انه نشوف القوات المسلحه بعيده من السياسه
بناء القوات المسلحه القوات المحترفه ما
عندها علاقه بالتنظيمات السياسيه
ولا فيها يمين ووات مسلحه سودانيه حق
السودان هي صمام اعمال هذا السودان عشان
كده بنقول نحن والله ماشي في التوافق نحن
متوقع انه ما تم توقيعه ايطالي يخرج هذه
البلاد من الوحدات
وحد شمله لنا وواحد صفنا عشان نبني هذا
البلد اهلنا عانوا سنين طويله وبلادنا
معنا سنين طويله ما عندنا اي طريقه غير
اننا نلبي نداء الشعب السوداني
البرهان رفض انتقاد المؤسسه العسكريه
مطالبا السياسيين بعدم التحدث في شؤون
الجيش والانشغال بترتيب صفوفهم متابع
الجيش
احنا بنقوله ونحنا نموت قدامك الكلام ده
دي مسؤوليتنا انه نحافظ على الجيش ده
بوحدته متماسك قوي يحمي هذا البلد ويحمي
الدوله السودانيه وبنقول لاخواننا
السياسيين بتتكلموا ان شاء الله
نبقى في السودان ولكن في موضوع اخر دانت
محكمه زوجه الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
وداد ببكر بتهمه الثراء الحرام بعد ان ظلت
تستلم راتب زوجها الاول بعد زواجها الثاني
باحد 10 عاما حكمت المحكمه بمصادره
العقارات والاموال والاحجار الكريمه التي
تملكها وداد بوبكر بالاضافه الى مصادرته
حسابين بنكين ودفع غرامه 100 مليون جنيه
سودانيه
في الخميس قال هو لكن بعد قليل
ساق مبتوره ومشهد قتل لا ينسى ماساه طفل
يمني مع انغام الحوثي
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه حذرت نقابه
الممرضين في بريطانيا من ان ضعف عدد اطقم
التمريض سيضربنا في اوائل فبراير في
محاوله زياده الضغط على حكومه ريش سوناك
وفقا لصحيفه
البريطانيه قالت الكليه الملكيه للتمريض
انه اذا لم يكن هناك تقدم في المحادثات
بحلول نهايه يناير فان المجموعه التاليه
من الاضرابات ستشمل جميع الاعضاء المؤهلين
في انجلترا وذلك للمره الاولى ياتي ذلك في
الوقت الذي يضغط فيه الوزراء من اجل اصدار
قوانين جديده تتطلب مستويات اقل من الخدمه
في ايام الاضراب من المتوقع ان يستغرق
التشريح حوالي سته اشهر لتمريره من خلال
البرلمان
المزيد معنا من لندن مراسله العربيه عروب
عبد الحق اهلا بك عروب بدايه تفاصيل عن
ماذا يمكن لنا ان نتوقع بالفعل
يعني مرحبا ميسون نحن نعلم بان هذا
الاسبوع سيكون هناك اضراب لي قطاع
الممرضين في 19 في 18 وال 19 من هذا الشهر
وهناك سيكون اضراب اخر لموظفي قطاع
الاسعاف الثالث والعشرين من همم هذا الشهر
ايضا وبالتالي يعني الوضع لا يبدوا همم لا
يبدو انه جيد بالنسبه همم
الاضرابات وبالنسبه لقطاع الصحه الوطنيه
بشكل عام هنا في بريطانيا ونحن نعلم بان
قطاع الصحه الوطن الوطني عاده ما يكون هو
مصدر فخر بالنسبه للبريطانيا ولكن يبدو
انه يحتاج الى اصلاحات كبيره جدا همم
اضراب الجديد مرتبط ب همم نتائج المفاوضات
نهايه هذا الشهر وبالتالي هل لدينا اي
معلومات اين وصلت هذه المفاوضات
يعني الاسبوع الماضي كانت النقابات قد
اعلنت عن فشل المفاوضات مع الحكومه فيما
يتعلق بالاجور نحن نعلم بان الممرضين
يطالبون برفع الاجور بنسبه يعني اما
توازي معدل التضخم او اعلى من معدل التضخم
ولكن هذا يعني الحكومه قالت بان هذا
الموضوع غير وارد لانها لا تت- لا تستطيع
تحمل تكاليف مثل هكذا رفع اجور اما
بالنسبه لموظفي الاسعاف همم هم لم يحددوا
يعني النسبه التي يريدون يريدونها ولكن
ايضا همم المفاوضات بينهم وبين همم
الحكومه والوزراء فشلت في الوصول الى همم
في الوصول الى اي همم
هل من خلال هذا التحدير من المتوقع ان
يكون في ربما تحرك اكثر من قبل الحكومه او
لا
يعني المفاوضات مستمره همم رديسونال قال
بانه همم يعني في خطاب في خطاب وبدايه هذا
العام قال بانه سيكشف اتباعا عن تفاصيل
الخطه التي يريد اتباعها من اجل التقليل
من هذه الاضطرابات سواء من خلال اصدار
تشريعات تحد من تحركات العمال بشكل عام او
من خلال الوصول الى اتفاق مع العمال حول
يعني نسبه همم تكون همم يعني تكون مرضيه
للطرفين للحكومه لانقابات خاصه نحن نعلم
بان هناك ارتفاع كبير في اسعار همم في
الاسعار في بريطانيا وتكاليف المعيشه
وبالتالي هذا الموضوع يعني ننتظر كيف سيتم
حله وهذا يدفعنا للتساؤل في ظل ارتفاع
اسعار المعيشه في بريطانيا ردود فعل
الشارع هل لا زالت داعمه في تفهم اللي مثل
هذه الاضطرابات
لا يبدو يعني ان الاضرابات هذه كانت تلقى
ااا يعني دعم اكبر ممكن ان نقول من قبل
الناس كنا قد تكلمنا مع العديد من الناس
هنا في الشارع البريطاني خلال الشهر
الماضي كانوا يتفهمون لماذا يضرب يعني
يضرب الممرضون وقطاع الاسعاف ولكن يبدو ان
هذا الدعم تراجع قليلا وذلك خاصه فيما
يتعلق بقطاع الريل ويزال سكك الحديديه
لانها عطلت حياه الناس واعمالهم اليوميه
يعني هناك بعض هناك شخص همم كنا قد تكلمنا
معه يقول بانه لم لم لا يستطيع الذهاب الى
عمله بسبب هذه الاضطرابات وهمم كانت هناك
ايضا بعض همم
التقارير التي اشارت بالارقام والنسب همم
بان هناك تراجع همم اصبح واضح اكبر يعني
همم ضد الاضطرابات خاصه فيما يتعلق باضراب
السكك الحديديه ولكن هناك تفهم همم تف
لاضراب موظفي قطاع الاسعاف لان نعلم بان
قطاع الصحه الوطني بشكل عام يواجه ازمه
كبيره من حيث اعداد المرضى او من حيث همم
اعداد المرضى في قطاع الاسعاف واعداد
المرضى الذين يريدون رؤيه طبيبهم العام
هناك تراكم حوالي سبع ملايين مريض على
لوائح الانتظار لا يزالوا يعني غير قادرين
على رؤيه همم على رؤيه الطبيب حتى
بالاسعاف هناك حوالي 50,000 همم مريض همم
يعني انتظروا اكثر من 12 ساعه خلال اليوم
الواحد من اجل همم يعني همم الحصول او
تلقي الى العلاج من لندن مراسله العربيه
عروب عبد الحق شكرا جزيلا لك
صحيفه
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني يدافع
عن وجود قوات امريكيه في بلاده مشيرا لانه
لم يحدد جدول زمنيا للانسحاب بها بحسب
الصحيفه فان السوداني اشار الى ان الحاجه
للقوات الاجنبيه لا تزال قائمه وان القضاء
على تنظيم داعش يحتاج الى المزيد من الوقت
في اشاره الى فرق القوات الامريكيه وقوات
حلفيه شمال الاطلسي التي تدرب وتساعد
الوحدات العراقيه في مكافحه التنظيم بحسب
الصحيفه
كنفت اللجنه العسكريه المشتركه في ليبيا
خمسه زائد خمسه اجتماعاتها اليوم في مدينه
سرت بعد توقف دا مع عده اشهر نتيجه طبعا
الصراعات الداخليه وحاله الجمود السياسي
في البلاد وصل وفدان لجنه بحضور مراقبه
وقف اطلاق النار المحليين
ونظرائهم الدوليين وبحضور المبعوث الاممي
الى ليبيا عبد الله باتيلا بحسب تصريحات
صحفيه العضو اللجنه العسكريه المشتركه
مصطفى يحيى فان ملف توحيد المؤسسه
العسكريه واستكمالا ملف خروج المرتزقه
والمقاتلين الاجانب والسلاح المنتشر في
البلاد ابرز الاشكاليات المطروحه على
طاوله الاجتماع
المزيد معنا من صرت مراسل العربيه محمد
مسعود اهلا بك محمد ماذا لدينا من معلومات
حول هذا الاجتماع
بمقر اللجنه العسكريه الدائم هنا بمدينه
سرت في وسط البلاد بعد ان كان اخر اجتماع
لللجنه في شهر اكتوبر من العامه الماضي
انطلق هذا الاجتماع بحضور المبعوث الاممي
الى ليبيا السيد عبد الله باتيلي وبحضور
ايضا المراقبين الدوليين مع البعثه الاميه
والفريق الامني الخاص بالباحثه الاميه في
هذا الاجتماع انتهى جزء الاول من هذا
الاجتماع بمغادره فريق المراقبين الدوليين
ما بعد اجتماعي مع نظرائه من المراقبين
المحليين وجرى خلال الجزء الاول مناقشه
الدور المراقبين المحليين في المحافظه على
وقت اطلاق النار وايضا تسجيل ايه خرقات في
الفتره الماضيه كانت حدثت خاصه من بعد
انتهاء عمل المراقبين في شهر اغسطس من
العام الماضي بفتح الطريقه الساحلي
وتامينه حتى هذه اللحظه الان
البلاد او مناطق الشرق نطق الحرب الاطار
عن حجم الخروقات
جهزتها اللجان الفرعيه التي حضرت هذا
الاجتماع نعلم ويعلم الساده المشاهدين بان
هناك عدد من اللجان الفرعيه ميسون مبثقت
عن اللجنه العسكريه بوفديها شرقا وغربا
منها لجنه ازاله الالغام وتفكيكا الالغام
التي حضرت هذا الاجماع ايضا اليوم ومنها
ايضا لجنه المراقبين ومن يتكفل ايه خروقات
على مدى الطريقه الساحلي منذ تقطيع
الاتفاقيه في جنيف من العامه الماضي
المختصه بوقفه النار كل هذه اللجان
الفرعيه حضرت هذا الاجتماع ايضا باضافه
الى مبعوثها الامم الى ليبيا وجاره تقديم
عدد من التقارير ولكن النظر لحساسيه
الموقف وللسريه همم يعني المعلومات لا يتم
الاف صاحب بشكل من الاشكال عن اي معلومات
تخرج من هذه القاعه خلفي الان ولكن يعني
عن طريق مصدرنا الخاصه نعلم ببعض هذه
المعلومات المؤكده من داخل في القاعه من
خلفي الان كل النقاش يجرى الان بعد مغادره
فريق المراقبين الدوليين والمحليين لقاعه
الاجتماعات حول استكمال باقي جدول اعمال
هذا الاجتماع الذي هو سوف يستمر لغايه يوم
الغد ويتم بعدها المغادره فقط من غادر
الان هو فريق المراقبين الدوري المحلين
ولا يزال السيد عبد الله
المبعوث الاممي يتواجد باب القاعه مع
اعضاء اللجنه العسكريه ويتركز او يتمحور
النقاش يعني يحول بنت اخراج المرتزقه
والعناصر الاجنبيه ورؤى او سبل توحيد
الموقف الدولي يعني بشكل واضح من خلال
تعاطي البعثه ودورها في دعم متطلبات او
دعم مطالب اللجنه العسكريه من الجهه او
حتى نتحدث عن دور اللجنه في تنفيذ هذا
المطلب هو باعتبار شيطان في التفاصيل فانه
الان يجرى الغوص في اعماق هذه هذه
تصريحات ربما
من سيره مراسل العربيه
في محافظه تعز في اليمن كان الطفل امير
العامري ذو الاربع سنوات احد ضحايا
الغامدي الحوثي والتي تسببت ببتريا
وفاه عمه وابن عمه نتابع القصه في هذا
التقرير
قتلت احلامي
وهو لم يتجاوز عامه الرابعه
هنا في محافظه تعز ترك لهم الطفل امير
شريف العامري اسيرا للاعاقه بعد ان تسبب
في بتر ساقه ولم يكتفي بذلك بل قتل عمه
وابن عمه شريكا اللعب حينها
هذا هو ابن عمار
في طريق الاطفال والنساء والمدنيين في
رحلتهم اليوميه لكسب رزقهم
من الجرائم الحرب لانه انت داري في هذا حي
سكاني اطفال ونساء وطبعا الماء ولا اكثرهم
معاهم اغنام معتمدين على الحطب ضروري ما
يخرجه
هذاك الطريقه
[موسيقى]
الف خير
وبينما يد الحوثي تزرع هذه الالغام هناك
يد اخرى تنزعها تتمثل في مشروع مسام لنزع
الالغام في اليمن الذي نزع منذ انطلاقه في
يوليو 2018 وحتى نهايه العام الماضي نحو
380,000 من الالغام والذخائر غير المتفجره
والهبوات الناسمه
جميع سكان بكين والذي يبلغ عددهم نتحدث عن
22 مليون بفيروس كورونا وذلك بحلول نهايه
هذا الشهر ووفقا لوكاله بلومبرج فقد اشارت
الدراسه الى ان 92% على الاقل من الاشخاص
في العاصمه الصينيه الصابون بكرونا بحلول
نهايه يناير بينما اصيب 76% بالفعل بحلول
22 ديسمبر الماضي كان الفايروس قد انتشر
بوتيرا سريعه في الصين بعد ان تخلت
الحكومه عن سياسه السفر كورونا الشهر
الماضي
الى اخبار الخامسه الرياضيه وعبد الله
درويش عبد الله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الى المجوز الرياضي توج السايق
القطري ناصر العطيه بطل الايراني داكار
الصحراوي في فئه السيارات للمره الثانيه
على التوالي والخامسه في السعوديه حيث
اقيم الرالي للعام الرابع على التوالي
العطيه الذي يحكم قبضته على صداره الترتيب
العام منذ المرحله الثالثه تقدم بفارق وصل
الى اكثر من ساعه عن الفرنسي سيباستيانو
حل الشاب والبرازيلي لوكس في المرتبه
الثالثه الفرنسي جيرل سجل اسرع توقيت في
مرحله الرابعه عشر والاخيره التي انطلقت
من الهفوف وانتهت في الدم
تتجه الانظار مساء اليوم نحو العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض حيث يقام كلاسيكو ريال
مدريد وبرشلونه في نهائي كاس السوبر
الاسبانيه على ملعب الملك فهد الدولي وكان
ريال مدريد قد تجاوز فالنسيا في نصف
النهائي بركلات الترجيح بعد نهايه الوقتين
الاصلي والاضافي بالتعادل بهدف بينما تخطى
برشلونه ريال بيتيس بركلات الترجيح ايضا
عقبه نهايه الوقت الاصلي بتعادل بالتعادل
بهدف الاضافي بهدفين استضافه السعوديه
السوبر الاسباني في جده خلال عام 2020
وتوج باللقب ريال مدريد بعد فوزه في
النهايه على اتلتيكو مدريد كما اقيمت
البطوله في الرياض لعام 2022 وتجاعيد ايضا
ريال مدريد باللقب على حسابي اتلتيكو
برشلونه من اجل التتوي
جدا للنهائي ولدي لاعبون معتدون دائما على
الفوز بالبطولات لذا اثق بفريقيا ولديهم
ميزه القوه الذهنيه
واللعب في ريال مدريد يعني انك مطالب
دائما بالالقاب بنزيما عاد من الاصابه
واضاف للفريق الكثير واعطى ناطقه كبيره
وسيساعدنا في ما تبقى من الموسم
زارنا كريستيانو في التدريبات وكان سعيدا
للغايه ومتحمسا لبدء تجربته مع النصر
السعوديه بلد جميل ورائع واتمنى له
التوفيق هنا واعتقد انه اتخذ القرار
الصحيح
نحن متحمسون للغايه هذا اللقب يعني الكثير
بالنسبه لنا خاصه امام ريال مدريد انه
كلاسيكو كبير وفي غايه الاهميه
سيحدث في المباراه ريال مدريد قوي الان
ويختلف عن الريال في الموسم الماضي
الارقام الموجوده لكي تتغير ودعني اذكرك
بانني كنت ايضا محظوظا في النهائيات كان
من الصعب الفوز على ريال بيتيس ونحن الان
بحاجه للتغلب على ريال مدريد
اخبار ثاني كذلك ان انشيلوتي لم يخسر اي
نهائي منذ عام 2010 فهذا يحفزني اكثر لقد
حصلوا على يوم راحه اضافي بسبب ان
مباراتهم امام فالنسيا كانت قبل مباراهنا
امام بيتيس واعتقد اننا لو لعبنا بنفس
اليوم سيكون الامر اكثر عدنا لكن هذا ليس
عذرا بكل تاكيد
الهلال العوده لسكه الانتصارات حين يستقبل
نظيره العداله في ختام منافسات الجوله
الثالثه عشر من الدوري السعودي لكره القدم
وجمع الهلال 26 نقطه من ثلاثه عشره مباراه
خاضها في المنافسه حتى الان فيما يحتل
العداله المركزه قبل الاخير بثمن نقاط من
اثنتي عشر امواج الهلال بمباراه واحده
خلال الجولات الاربعه الاخيره فيما يبحث
العداله عن فوزه ثالث في المسابقه
للابتعاد عن مراكز الهوب
حافظ النصر على صداره الدوري السعودي
بتعادله دون اهداف مع نظيره الشباب ضمن
منافسات الاسبوع الثالث عشر من المسابقه
وفشل الفريقان في استغلال الفرص التي سمحت
له مع طيله شوطي المباراه النصر رفع رصيده
الى 29 نقطه حفظ فيها على صداره الترتيب
في ما اصبح لدى الشباب 26 نقطه تراجع على
يثرها للمرتبه الثالثه في سلم ترتيب
الدوري السعودي
[موسيقى]
يتجدد الصراع بين ارسنال وتوتنهام عندما
يلتقيان في دربي شمال لندن في الجوله ال
20 من الدوري الانجليزي لكره القدم ويتصدر
وارسنال الترتيب برصيد اربعين اربعين نقطه
بفارق خمس نقاط عن اقرب ملاحقه مانشستر
سيتي فيما يحتل المركز الخامس برصيد
يسعى روما للتقدم الى المربع الذهبي في
الدوري الايطالي عندما يستقبل فيورنتينا
في الاسبوع الثامن عشر من البطوله ولم
يخسر ابناء مورينيو في خمس مباريات
متتاليه بجميع المسابقات وحسم تاهله
الاسبوع الماضي الى الدور الربع النهائي
من كاس ايطاليا ويسع روما للتقدم نحو فرق
الاربعه في المقدمه حيث يملك احدى وثلاثين
نقطه بينما يملك بيورنتينا ثلاثا 23
نهايه الموجز الرياضي نعود الان الى ميسون
تفضل لميسون
[موسيقى]
استقر السعر بيتكوين بيتكوين اليوم فوق
مستوى 20 الف دولار بعد تجاوزه لاول مره
منذ اكثر من شهرين في تعاملات امس ارتفعت
الحصه السوقيه لاكبر عمله مشفره الى
40% من سوق العملات المشفره الاجمالي
بعدما همم خفضت من مكاسبها بنسبه 8%
تقريبا على الجانب الاخر شهدت قيمته
التداولات على العملات المشفره نشاطا
كبيرا اذا ارتفعت بنسبه 80% خلال ال 24
ساعه الاخيره مسجله تداولات بقيمه 89
مليار
بهذا الخبر نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
الخامس الشكر المتابعه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]